[Music]
blackheads and clogged ears can be super
uncomfortable but it's important to
leave any picking and prodding to the
experts
this is how professionals treat and
clean five body parts including the
teeth
scalp
and toenails
this teeth cleaning method is called
guided biofilm therapy or gbt
the goal is to remove biofilm from the
teeth
it's a layer of bacteria that's
responsible for bleeding gums bad breath
and some dental infections and diseases
unlike plaque you can't see or feel
biofilm because it's so tiny
that's why dental hygienist faye donald
is painting each tooth with this purple
liquid
it's an organic colored dye called
biofilm disclosure
it stains early biofilm which is less
than three days old pink and mature
biofilm which is more than three days
old blue
donald wants to disrupt early biofilm
before it has the chance to mature into
plaque
now the cleaning process begins
she's using a tool called airflow max
which acts like a gentle jet wash inside
the mouth
it uses a combination of warm water and
soluble antimicrobial powder
donald says it'll remove 100 percent of
the biofilm from the teeth even in the
dark warm areas that the biofilm likes
to hide it also removes stains
now that that's done she uses a
descaling kit called liaison no pain it
uses ultrasonic vibrations to remove any
remaining hard buildup or plaque from
the teeth
unlike old plaque removal methods there
is no scraping involved so it won't
scratch or damage the tooth surface
[Music]
earwax can be soupy hard crumbly soft
and even moldy
professionals will scrape suck
or flush it out
the removal method depends on the
consistency of the wax and where it's
located inside the ear canal
here we're looking at hard impacted wax
but this wax is way too impacted so
suction isn't working
he switches to a coth horn hook number
six which is a tiny metal right angle
hook with a pointy end
it's so small that boland can maneuver
the hook around the debris and gently
dig it out of the ear canal
it's important that he carefully digs
and scrapes out the debris in stages
otherwise painful damage to the ear can
occur
the wax became like this after the
patient tried to self-treat it with
water-based drops
[Music]
earwax is important for ear health so
bolan says that it should only ever be
removed if it's bothering the patient
and in that case it's important to visit
a specialist to get it professionally
removed
felicia brown created a holistic scalp
cleanse for clients with serious
dandruff buildup to prep the scalp she
sprays the cleansing product directly on
the client's head
now she's scratching and freeing the
scalp of dandruff dead skin and anything
else that's clogging it
once the build up is removed she sprays
the hair with the cleansing product
again and lets it sit for 15 to 20
minutes
the scalp is shampooed and thoroughly
massaged
she says clients usually experience
immediate relief after the treatment
the scalp cleanse was made for patients
with psoriasis eczema dermatitis
dandruff or a clogged scalp
lori holloway is a nail technician who
cleans thick impacted toenails
she starts by soaking the feet in a
whirlpool foot bath that contains foot
soap and foot salt this helps soften and
disinfect the skin and loosen up the
debris
she treats the bottom of the foot with a
callus remover
nail nippers reduce the length of the
toenail and a cuticle pusher pushes back
the skin that's stuck to the nail plate
she uses an ingrown toenail sidewall
cleaner to carefully pull out all of the
impacted debris from the sides and
underneath the toenail
she often uses an electric file to
reduce the thickness of the nail
when a toenail is too thick it hits the
top and front of the shoe this is what
causes it to grow abnormally which can
lead to infection or injury
[Music]
claudia columbo is an esthetician who
professionally performs blackhead
extractions
before the extraction process begins she
massages the face to drain the lymph
nodes and gently cleanses the skin
then she pre-softens the skin with a
warm towel and an enzyme treatment this
makes it easier for the blackheads to be
extracted
that silver spatula is actually an
ultrasonic skin scrubber which columbo
uses to exfoliate the skin
the ultrasonic waves help loosen and
remove oil and dirt from the pores
she starts gently extracting the
blackheads with her fingers
not much pressure is needed since the
skin has already been prepped and
softened
it's important to replenish the skin
with minerals and nutrients that may
have been lost during the process
in this case colombo applies some
chlorophyll and copper complex to
replenish magnesium and copper in the
skin
she leaves it to incubate and then
applies a blue light to help heal the
skin
the light also allows the ingredients to
penetrate deeper into the pores
lastly she applies a hydro jelly mask to
soothe the skin
you